i
[Música]
al menos 30 palestinos entre ellos 10
menores de edad tres israelíes murieron
en los recientes enfrentamientos en
jerusalén que escaló a varios ataques
aéreos el armamento israelí alcanzó un
edificio en la franja de gaza desde
donde fueron lanzados más de 130 cohetes
uno de ellos alcanzó un bus en un
suburbio de la ciudad de tel aviv
hiriendo a seis personas
jornada número 14 de protestas
ciudadanas en colombia durante su visita
a la ciudad de cali el presidente iván
duque anunció la gratuidad de la
educación universitaria y tecnológica
para los más pobres a partir del segundo
semestre del 2021 esto mientras el país
se prepara para una nueva jornada de
movilizaciones masivas convocadas para
este miércoles
y en rusia nueve personas fallecieron
entre ellos siete menores de edad y dos
adultos veinte más resultaron heridos
después de un tiroteo perpetrado en una
escuela de la ciudad de kazán en la
república rusa de tatarstán a unos 800
kilómetros de moscú
el atacante un joven de 19 años fue
detenido por las autoridades locales e
identificado como ex alumno de esa
escuela
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález gracias por estar con nosotros
hasta ahora vamos a comenzar en el medio
oriente en donde al menos 30 ciudadanos
palestinos entre ellos 10 menores de
edad y también 3 israelíes murieron en
jerusalém en donde la atención entre
ciudadanos palestinos e israelíes
llevaron a varios ataques aéreos más de
130 cohetes fueron disparados desde la
franja de gaza y alcanzaron a sobrevolar
el espacio aéreo de la ciudad de tel
aviv que es la ciudad más poblada del
país uno de los proyectiles impactó un
autobús en la zona de holón que es un
suburbio de tel aviv dejando allí a seis
personas heridas esto en respuesta a los
ataques aéreos israelíes que provocaron
el colapso de un edificio residencial de
13 pisos en la franja de gaza el primer
ministro de israel benjamin netanyahu
advirtió que jamás pagará un precio muy
alto mientras que los líderes del grupo
hamas indicaron que están listos ante
una escalada por parte de israel estos
enfrentamientos provocaron llamados por
parte de la comunidad internacional por
ejemplo la a un lado
y la unión europea han pedido el cese
inmediato de la violencia mientras que
la liga árabe ha denunciado la violencia
contra gaza el contexto de esta nueva
confrontación entre israel y palestina
en el siguiente informe de andré amaya
[Música]
las nubes se mezclaban en gasa con el
humo que dejaron los bombardeos aéreos
este martes por parte de israel- la
escalada de violencia entre el estado de
hebreo y las milicias palestinas sigue
dejando muertos y heridos en este
conflicto el blanco también ha sido la
población civil
el lunes la aparente calma que se sentía
en jerusalén se transformó en una noche
caótica luego de que militantes
palestinos dispararan cohetes desde gaza
hacia la ciudad vieja el grupo hamas
está detrás del ataque israel no tardó
en responder con decenas de bombardeos
aéreos pero que revivió el conflicto
israelí-palestino en los últimos días
los disturbios fueron impulsados por un
intento de los colonos judíos para
apoderarse de casas de familias
palestinas construidas en el este de
jerusalén una zona de la ciudad anexada
por israel pero que los palestinos
consideran como la futura capital de su
eventual estado independiente
durante una marcha judía para conmemorar
el día de jerusalén decenas de
palestinos se atrincheraron a las
afueras de la mezquita de al-aqsa en la
ciudad vieja en la llamada marcha de la
bandera los judíos conmemora la captura
del este de jerusalén por parte de
israel en 1967 cuando durante la guerra
de los seis días tomó el control
efectivo de toda la ciudad para los
palestinos esto no es más que una
provocación pero las tensiones no se
intensificaron este fin de semana sino
antes desde mediados de abril cuando la
policía puso barreras de seguridad fuera
de la puerta de damasco en la ciudad
vieja impidiendo a los palestinos
reunirse durante la noche en el inicio
del mes sagrado musulmán del ramadán la
onu la unión europea estados unidos y
rusia han expresado su preocupación por
la escalada de violencia e instaron a
todas las partes a mostrar moderación
nos vamos ahora hasta colombia el
presidente de ese país iván duque viajó
a la ciudad de cali epicentro de las
protestas ciudadanas que cumplen ya 14
días el mandatario sostuvo allí
encuentros con autoridades locales y
también con su equipo negociador
desplegado
a buscar una salida a la crisis social
que está viviendo colombia la visita
tiene lugar en medio de otra jornada de
manifestaciones bloqueos
desabastecimiento principalmente en cali
que es la tercera ciudad de importancia
en ese país todo esto como parte de las
manifestaciones contra algunas políticas
del gobierno del presidente iván duque
colombia se prepara para una nueva
jornada de paro nacional que está
prevista para mañana miércoles esto
mientras persisten los enfrentamientos y
los hostigamientos entre ciudadanos y la
policía local
el mandatario colombiano anunció que en
el segundo semestre de este año será
otorgada la matrícula gratuita para
educación superior universitaria técnica
y tecnología para los estratos 1 2 y 3
que son los más bajos de la escala
social colombiana a continuación
explicamos cuáles son las principales
exigencias del comité nacional del paro
en las negociaciones que está
sosteniendo con el gobierno de colombia
sin acuerdos así concluyó la reunión
entre el presidente iván duque y el
comité organizador del paro que expuso
el mandatario su amplio pliego de
peticiones de emergencia tanto
económicas como sociales que datan de
las masivas marchas de 2019 y que buscan
soluciones a la crisis política y social
que ha causado las protestas y que se ha
visto agravada por la pandemia de kobe
19 la retirada de la fallida reforma
tributaria del gobierno ha dado paso a
otras exigencias abanderadas por una
renta básica de emergencia para 6
millones de hogares en condición de
pobreza y vulnerabilidad por un período
de seis meses las propuestas tendrían un
costo aproximado de 81 billones de pesos
anuales según cálculos de economistas
locales la mayoría casi 74 billones
destinados a la renta básica por ello
los expertos dudan de la viabilidad para
llevar a cabo unas propuestas económicas
tan ambiciosas a la luz de la situación
fiscal del país con el 49 2% de la
población trabajando en la informalidad
y más del 42 por ciento en situación de
pobreza si bien el presupuesto del
comité está muy por encima de la fallida
reforma tributaria de casi 25 billones
de pesos colombianos
el comité difiere del gobierno
los economistas tradicionales en la
forma de recaudar los fondos para estas
ayudas sociales proponen que la banca
central haga préstamos la monetización
de las reservas internacionales
impuestos a los más ricos o una apuesta
por la producción nacional vamos al
continente americano y nos vamos hasta
europa en rusia asciende a 9 el número
de víctimas mortales entre ellas siete
menores de edad y dos adultos después de
un tiroteo en una escuela en la ciudad
de kazán la capital de la república rusa
de tatarstán en el sur del país según
los son reportes oficiales otras veinte
personas resultaron heridas mientras que
el atacante un joven de 19 años y ex
alumno de esa escuela fue arrestado por
la policía local xavier colás desde
moscú la capital rusa nos da más
detalles de esta situación de lo que se
registra allí en el siguiente reporte
el auto de la matanza es un joven de 19
años que había estudiado en esa misma
escuela el arma estaba registrada a su
nombre parece que obtuvo el permiso hace
menos de dos semanas y estaba
desequilibrado el presidente ruso
vladimir putin ha ordenado que se
establezcan criterios más estrictos de
cara a la obtención del permiso de armas
en uso en el hospital clínico infantil
de tataristán están ingresados 18 niños
6 de ellos están en estado crítico a
estas horas se saben algunas cosas sobre
el asesino que ese grado allí mismo en
esa escuela hace cuatro años y entró
después en la universidad donde estudió
como especialista en informática sus
profesores los recuerdan como un chico
callado y respetuoso unos días antes de
la matanza el atacante puso en marcha un
canal en telegram que bautizó como dios
donde se autodenominaba como un ser
superior por la mañana se fotografió a
sí mismo con una máscara donde se veía
la palabra dios afirmando que iba a la
escuela a cometer una matanza y que
después se iba a suicidar claro que al
final ha acabado entregándose a la
policía en otros temas miles de personas
se manifestaron en pueblos y ciudades de
mianmar cuando se cumplen ya 100 días
del golpe militar que derrocó al
gobierno civil liderado por aún
sanssouci los manifestantes participaron
en marchas caravanas y protestas
relámpago todo esto para evadir a las
fuerzas de seguridad mientras los grupos
anti golpistas renovaron sus llamados a
derrocar a esta junta militar condenada
internacionalmente por matar a cerca de
700 civiles en las protestas ciudadanas
según lo indica la asociación para la
asistencia de presos políticos y también
por haber detenido a más de 3.000
personas entre ellas a la respuesta al
líder de ese país a un sandwich
y para el cierre veamos lo que tenemos
publicado a esta hora en france 24 punto
com nuestra página web se encuentra en
portada en este momento los
enfrentamientos entre israel y palestina
que estábamos reportando al inicio de
este informativo y también otras
noticias destacadas de la jornada en
américa latina europa y el mundo
y con esto llegamos al final de las
noticias en france 24 siga con nuestra
programación muy buenas noches
[Música]